the Georgia Senate runoff has gone
completely off the rails as Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker has
accused Rafael Warnock of sexual assault
and physical assault
what what is he talking about none of us
know and increasingly the question is
being asked does Walker even have any
idea what he's talking about is this
defamation let's look at the clip this
is you know to say it's gotten ugly is
an understatement I genuinely don't know
whether Walker has any idea what he's
saying but that would not be an excuse
here that would not be an excuse this is
the height of dangerous irresponsibility
Herschel Walker spoke yesterday at some
event he's doing these campaign events
All Over Georgia
and he said you know there was physical
abuse and there was sexual abuse who did
it
it has to be Senator Raphael Warnock now
I'll tell you what this relates to in a
moment
here's the clip he's not what you that
he's claimed to be
some of the best people no one and best
said
a man said that was a sexual abuse that
was physical abuse I'm like who did that
it had to be centered Raphael Warner
because he was responsible for it y'all
didn't hear about that did you he don't
want to talk about those things because
he don't want you to know that he think
you're going to be he is a good senator
for you I'm telling you right now it is
time for a change yeah now
if you can make heads or tails out of
that unintelligible word salad
by all means go ahead and do it
this is so difficult because Walker
clearly is saying
that Raphael Warnock sexually abused and
physically abused a kid okay it's clear
that he's saying those words but at the
same time
it's never really clear that Walker has
any idea what he's saying and I know
every time we talk about this oh David
well that's not really issues oriented
or he has a brain injury from football
that hasn't been said or this is because
of his dissociative identity disorder
that he says these things that that's
not the explanation that they're giving
we have to go by what he is saying
and there's a real question as to
whether this is potentially defamatory
now again it's not clear Walker knows
what he's saying because it's never
clear he knows what he's saying but what
this is about relates to allegations
that camp counselors
20 years ago at a camp where Warnock
um uh Warnock ran the camp but there's
no allegations that Warnock did any of
this stuff the allegation is that a 12
year old boy
was forced to sleep outside at the camp
and had urine tossed on him by Camp
counselors okay
absolutely horrible allegations and the
incident was investigated in 2001-2002
it resulted in no charges law
enforcement later called it a
miscommunication and it was never even
alleged that Warnock did any of this
stuff now you could say well if indeed
it happened maybe Raphael Warnock who
was running the camp had some ultimate
responsibility but but the idea that
Warnock is a sexual or physical abuser
is completely out of this world now the
question then becomes is this defamatory
uh because in general you know if some
random person on Twitter with five
followers tweets that Raphael Warnock
sexually and physically abused someone
it's not defamatory uh because it's not
damaging to Warnock but when we look at
the requirements for defamation the uh
information that is allegedly defamatory
must be published well that means that
it's public and here's the video we
looked at the video so it certainly
meets that standard the person being
defamed was clearly identified by the
statement meaning is it clear that
Walker is talking about his opponent
Senator Rafael Warnock I would argue
it's clear that it is he says Raphael
Warnock is the one who did this there's
no confusion as to whether he means
someone else by that name or anything
like that number three the remarks have
a negative effect on the person's
reputation that's the question
we don't know yet but if it starts to
spread in such a tight race
the completely baseless allegation that
Warnock is a physical and sexual abuser
you could argue that those remarks have
a negative impact on warnock's
reputation
number four is is the information
demonstrably false well it's hard to
prove negatives but there's certainly no
evidence that these allegations about
Warnock are true and the police
investigation generally into this
incident at the camp which isn't even
alleged to be warnox doing
found no legal wrongdoing and it didn't
even allege that Warnock was the one
doing it and then number five the
defendant is at fault in other words
that it is indeed Herschel Walker who um
uh made made these claims and made them
uh in a way that is consistent with with
uh um Reckless disregard or there's
different different standards in
different states you arguably have a
defamation case here now what I care
more about is can we just get Raphael
Warnock over the finish line
before some new thing comes up that gets
in the way of this campaign and I think
again without defending or attacking the
individual incident and what supposedly
happened to this 12 year old what Walker
said is not even remotely based in fact
then the crowd just sort of goes along
with it the real disturbing part of all
of this is that this race even went to a
runoff that's really the disturbing part
that the Georgia voters Georgia
Republican voters and this is a theme
that we are following in their
desperation to not vote for a Democrat
they are voting for someone who is
completely unqualified doesn't have a
sensible position that he can articulate
on any issue and on a personal level is
a complete hypocrite with regard to the
policy positions that he sort of claims
to Advocate to the extent that we can
understand him uh completely against
abortion in all cases no exception well
he urged two women and paid for two
women to get abortions
um it says we we need we need men not to
be absent fathers he's an absent father
to multiple kids that we know about it's
not even totally clear to me how many
kids it is and on and on and on that
alone is not a reason to vote against
him but the totality of the situation
should lead to this guy losing by 40
points and instead it was so close
within one point with neither candidate
able to secure fifty percent of the vote
that now we have a runoff on December
6th let's really hope that our Georgia
friends who vote in Georgia get out
there and make this extraordinarily
important vote we'll have live coverage
on December 6th that's the day of the
runoff
everything you do online can be tracked
by your ISP by Tech platforms the
government hackers everyone should be
using a VPN every time you connect to
the internet you turn it on once you
forget about it it's easy many vpns
secretly record your browsing and
download history but our sponsor private
internet access is the only VPN with the
bulletproof commitment to never doing
that because they're the only VPN that
has proven their no log policy multiple
times in court their systems are also
independently audited by Deloitte to
verify no logging private internet
access has a Next Generation server
infrastructure with IP addresses in 83
countries and all 50 U.S states it's one
of the only vpns fast enough for
streaming video and downloading large
files for instance private internet
access lets me access a bunch of great
international soccer I can't otherwise
get VP ends can be very helpful with the
upcoming World Cup and private internet
access has a 30-day money-back guarantee
24 7 customer support and my audience
gets 82 percent off that's just two
dollars and 11 cents a month plus three
months free go to
piavpn.com David the link is in the
podcast notes